dazu warten ich habe mich heute schön in
schale geworfen extra ein hemd angezogen
haare nach hinten mega frisch gemacht
für das heutige video denn herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einer weiteren
episode von luca reagiert auf die
die betten
aber naja meine damen und herren war das
erste video was sie uns heute zusammen
angeschaut haben das heißt kann ja
eigentlich nur besser werden
[Musik]
warum seid ihr so allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten video uns war es
ein video in dem ein mädchen klavier
spielt da bin ich auf jeden fall mega
gespannt aber wollte ich mich komplett
verarscht jeder weiß dass das lied so
geht das gerade gehörte dann allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten video
pous-tio und sprüht man sich jetzt auf
die füße auf die straße
was allerdings direkt zum nächsten video
das auf install mit dem hashtag luca
reagiert hochgeladen wurde und was ist
ein witz wir hören mal rein
das sagte ein asiate wenn er sein bein
gebrochen hat keine ahnung aber knacki
knacki nagasaki
das ist ein deutscher und ein produzent
autor und sind von sprechen hört kann
nicht so wieder sachen nein oh wie süß
ich finde so etwas so nice werde mir
videos von hunden schickt ihr hund hat
sich immer im kreis getreten dann auf
den boden gelegt das neueste ist ich
habe jetzt auch ein hund kriegs gleich
das leckerli dann das erinnert mich sehr
stark an sandra im jump haus also die
person die das hier mit dem hashtag luca
reagiert auf instagram hochgeladen haben
waren anscheinend auf unserem campus
unterwegs und die haben mir sogar noch
ein video geschickt
ich lass das
so stehen herum da hat man ihn am kinn
eingang auf jeden fall
warum warten 11 blondinen vom kino
eingang keine ahnung hat es mir bitte
sagen
ein jaguar im dschungel sieht wenn man
jaguar dschungel wie keine ahnung
weglaufen für nichts einsteigen darum zu
tragen mensch ist schön endlich mal
wieder ein vernünftiges video hier schön
in der natur einfach eine junge der ein
gänseblümchen nimmt was schauen wie es
weitergeht
die gehe ich habe mich menschlich
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend dritten track
pack apropos luca - shopping.de da
kommen am 10 615 neue klamotten online
von jeder bestellung der neuen klamotten
werden wir einen euro an die stiftung
gegen rassismus spenden ihr bekommt auch
wieder 1000 signiertes ticker falls sie
dort ein produkt bestellt und das tolle
ist vor einigen tagen hat sogar ein user
eine wissenschaftlich überprüft
rezension über den luca shop abgegeben
die sachen von lugano shop.de haben die
qualität von kik dass ich wieder nur
klatschen durchlaufe das tut mir
wirklich leid aber ich habe dann einfach
keine andere reaktion und wo wir auch
gerade beim thema luca shop sind das
hier ist das nächste video - shop.de
weil ich jetzt auch mein bruder luca -
shop und der helligkeit ist dass ich
sowas mitmachen würde nicht passieren
konnte dass babys konnte auch dir für
deine tanzkünste er ich kann das
tatsächlich auch mitteilte dass babys
und ich sag neuer trend sein buch
irgendwo rum schmeißen eine neue ausgabe
vom lud royal wir haben uns wieder mal
in die tiefen von youtube gestützt und
haben erstaunliches entdeckt okay da bin
ich aber jetzt echt mal gespannt
lucio giornale falls sie es nicht kennen
dass es eine der renommiertesten
journalistisch versierten intellektuell
hochwertigen bildungs reichen
wissenschaftlich wieder vip
nachrichtensendungen luca ist ein
roboter
auf seinen sehr ekel jährigen dem
youtube kanal in dem video what's up
feld spricht luca am ende schneller als
ein hund ich spreche schneller als ein
hund muss gar nicht dass hunde überhaupt
sprechen können
heute nehmen an dass luca falsch
eingestellt worden es hoffentlich
explodiert er bald damit wir ihn nicht
mehr sehen müssen dass für die operette
ich hab auch dazu ich glaube ich und
einfach nur noch sagen
bis bald euer switches look journal team
[Musik]